hello everyone and welcome to the world
blitz championship after three days of
rapid we now have the two days of blitz
and uh here's the game from the final
round of the uh of the event it's levon
arun versus daniel dubov and one of
these uh two gentlemen is leading the
tournament after
the initial 11 rounds tomorrow we're
gonna have nine more rounds of blitz uh
and it's a it's a really crazy game uh
you guys are going to enjoy it it's a
miniature basically but um the one that
i decided to show and there are so many
games being played if you have any that
you know you thought that was really
spectacular use hashtag suggestion and i
will do my best uh to cover it so that
being said uh let's check out the game
uh will uh no derby abductor will be
able to do some damage in uh blitz as
well or will we have someone else uh
climb the top so arunyan with the white
pieces opens with e4 uh for some reason
that's not happening uh with e4 we have
c5 knight to f3 d6 and now c3 going for
the alapin variation uh against uh the
sicilian defense we have knight to f6
and now bishop to e2 we have knight beat
to d7 and now d3 we have g6 and now
castles uh sort of a system that i live
on place uh for for such a quick time
formats with bishop to g7 and bishop to
e3 we have castles by do both uh and now
there is a game where knight f2 d2 was
played but here he plays knight beat to
d2 and it is now already as of move
eight that we have a completely new game
so b6 uh duval prepares stephen keto the
light square bishop and uh levon strikes
in the center with the d4 with bishop to
b7 now threatening to win the e4 pawn
and levon advances the pawn all the way
to d5 we've broke the e8 and now a4
grabbing more space on the queen side we
have a6 and now rook to e1
we have queen to c7 now do both still
winning with the e6 move you you really
want to
take care of this uh advance the d5 pawn
in the center but he wants to
develop as many pieces as possible
before committing to this so bishop to
c4 we have knight to g for uh
remaneuvering the knight over to e5 and
bishop to f4 now uh we have knight g to
e5 and here we have a trade in the
center knight captures knight captures
attacking the bishop here and the bishop
back to f1 with e6 finally do both
attacks the center here and d captures
an e6 with rook captures on e6 and now
knight to c4 uh offering more traits so
if black captures you can play bishop
captures on c4 so dubo just brings the
other rook into the game and now f3
strengthening the center here uh which
makes sense as the bishop is attacking
it and both rooks that are doubled on
the defa e file are attacking it uh here
b5 challenging the knight here a
captures eight captures and now knight
captures an e5 we have d captures on e5
uh yes you are uh closing the file where
you had uh both of your rooks but uh
with f3 being played that's never gonna
be be useful so it's better to capture
with the opponent shift the rocks maybe
over to the d file uh or to the open a
file so here bishop back to e3 and now
c4 and now what do you play here the
material is completely equal uh both
players with a bishop player both
players with a rook pair both players
have a queen uh levon attacks with b3
all right this is the only way to make
progress and he played it fairly quickly
we have c captures on b3 uh queen
captures on b3 and now dubo needs to
play bishop to a6 but he played bishop
to c6 to defend uh the spawn uh point is
if if you capture it with the bishop
then we can just play rook to b8 and
it's going to be a very very sad bishop
for example bishop captures on b5
we could even capture it first bishop
captures queen captures and then we just
play queen captures on c3 yeah
maybe
rook to b8 isn't all that impressive you
can just defend it with c4 so it would
just be trading um trading off pawns
however uh there is one problem with
bishop to c6 and levon found it pretty
much instantly he played c4 and now he's
threatening to create a pass pawn with c
captures on b5 and uh you have to
capture on c4 so b captures on c4 we
have bishop captures on c4 attacking the
rook on e6 and now
rook 6 and e7
getting the rook out of harm's way and
now comes rook to a7 attacking the queen
and you can't really move the queen if
you move the queen yes you're defending
the rook and everything but just bishop
captures an f7 check and that's it you
can't capture with the rook otherwise
you're getting checkmated can get [ __ ]
queen captures on g7 checkmate
or
if you try something else came to a fade
we can just capture here on e8 and if
rook captures an a7 we can play bishop
captures in c6 if rook a3 attacks the
queen we're gonna defend our bishop
queen to b7 we're up a light square
bishop and of course we are completely
winning here so instead after rook to a7
we have bishop to b7 uh dubai blocks
this and now uh we have a bishop to a6
here uh rook the b1 is a bit more
precise uh simply adding another
attacker but with bishop to a6
it doesn't work
just as well because the rook on e1 is
undefended and double immediately
attacks it we have queen to a5 attacking
the rook on e1 and now rook to c1 but
now uh you have to play queen captures
on a6 and hope for the best you have to
play captures captures and captures and
play this position with a bishop pairing
a rook pair against the queen uh bishop
and rook and black would would still
have chances here it's not easy for
white to break through here especially
in the blitz game but instead after rook
to c1 bishop captures an a6 was played
which seems like a perfectly fine idea
but the problem is the position is now
completely winning for levon uh feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for him well i give you a couple of
seconds basically reach the position
from the thumbnail
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh
finding the quickest way to reach the
position from the thumbnail and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's rook capture sun e7 and now
look at this you can't recapture because
the back rank is incredibly weak if rook
captures an e7 but if you don't capture
the the position is also completely lost
uh
for example rook to f8 we're just going
to play rook to a7 and we're up um
we're up material and there there's not
another good move that you can make here
it's a really really bad position for
black but the dubo still hoped for the
best and he accepted the rook he played
rook captures on e7 uh and now comes
queen to b8 with check and now look at
this you can't cover with the bishop you
can't cover with the queen you can't
cover with the rook because the queen
just gobbles all of them up so you have
to cap defend with the bishop but now
after bishop to f8 we have bishop to h6
a threatening checkmate and instead of
resigning here uh dooba please one more
move and this will show you exactly what
kind of a guy dubois is always having a
good time and you know just trying
absolutely everything to win even though
the chances of it happening aren't that
great but here uh dual flight bishop the
c8 it's it's such a sneaky movie that uh
says all right maybe maybe levon will
capture with the rook because if he
captures with the rook i can deliver
this queen to e1 checkmate but it uh
didn't work levon of course capture with
the queen and he was now in this
position on move 33 that daniel lubovo
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you're getting
checkmated on the next move and that's
it game over
so really impressive game by lavon and
just so i don't forget uh here are the
standings uh after 11 rounds of the
first day of the blitz those of you who
still are not interested don't watch i
don't want to spoil anything for you but
for those of you who are interested here
are the uh rankings so levon is leading
the tournament uh with uh at nine points
so half a point ahead of everyone else
uh then with eight and a half points we
have martin kravitz uh bassem amin and
daniel duo with eight points we have a
lot of people uh vladimir fedorsev
alexander grisham young
magnus carlson arjun
kumar parham
uh and with seven and a half we have um
uh java kircindaro
and so on and so on these are only the
the top 15. so you can see uh it's a
it's a very very interesting tournament
and uh well
okay it's important to play well on day
one but if you play really really well
on the second day it will also
mean that you will climb uh
climb on top of everyone
so that's the game and the standings
hope you guys enjoyed that like i said
if you have any of your own favorites do
you use hashtag suggestion and i will
show those games uh i would like to
thank david kimura evgeny brisken uh eat
frangos.com shirley chang and george
julian g glaulaboon for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this most
impressive event until it finishes uh
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day